what's it like to head up an empire and
I'm gonna call it that you can quit with
the term if you like but you probably
you probably have to save a lot of
control and I imagine that's difficult
for something like I was joking during
the break I saw you at Auto one morning
when I went there for brunch you're
still there you're still involved but
just by necessity you must be pulled in
a lot of different direction well I've
you know everyone that's the executive
chef or the general manager is
effectively a partner in all my
operations and they came up through the
organization it wasn't like I went on
Craigslist through a dartboard through a
daughter in a job board and said hey
let's open a restaurant in X it was more
like I've been really cultivating the
talent that came through my organization
and the only reason we open new
restaurants is to to accommodate my
people that would eventually go work for
somebody else so we've opened new
restaurants but they're always with the
core team that have all worked with me
so seating power to them is natural and
it's what they want and part of what
I've really realized over time is I
don't have to be the smartest or the
youngest or the coolest guy in the room
I just got to be in the room and that
makes me happy and it makes them feel
empowered so that they know that their
message is my message in my messages
there you've put your imprimatur on
eataly there's one here in New York I've
seen it in Chicago as well moving to
Boston - what's your plan for growth
with either what's your involvement with
it first of all and well I'm a partner
in the American versions right now we're
talking about rolling us all into the
International thing Italy is about
fundamentally about shopping eating
tasting and learning and my message is
always let's get them all of these
fantastic products but we don't want
them to just come in and eat we want
them really to come away from Italy with
groceries it's about cooking at home
very quickly here if you were to open a
new restaurant in a certain region
country what are you looking at what
would be interesting to you outside of
the States there what you mean in the
world yeah I love Shanghai yeah I love
Hong Kong I love Australia I love
anyplace where there's beautiful sea
magnificent markets and people that are
hungry